I don't listen to music with profanities
I know that Oliver is new to Faith and I
pray he will be inspired to make songs
in the future that truly honor God Matt
I know you say that the language isn't a
problem but would you let your kids
speak that way I wouldn't let my kids
talk about selling their souls in a
metaphorical way if my six-year-old came
down from cleaning his room and said I'm
tired of selling my soul Dad working all
day for this terrible allowance if he
said that to me he'd be in trouble like
five times over but that doesn't mean
that adults can't use that language and
this is actually important because if
you're saying that when an artist puts
his Lamentations and frustrations to
words that he must only use words that
we would allow a six-year-old to say
mother trucker dude then you really have
put some very unnecessary and
suffocating limitations on his artistic
expression